all right so well let's let's use this
as a point to uh jump to the next story
oh yeah so this is something
i was talking about earlier it's from
the daily mail democratic
representatives right to cable companies
including at t
and comcast and streamers amazon and
hulu demanding they drop
fox news oan and newsmax over
misinformation
i didn't want to jump into this like
we're coming off the other segment but
we did that whole spiel with
the coca-cola thing but uh this is
interesting to me because basically we
can see like disney
claiming muppets are racist and all that
stuff so so let me get this straight
disney is allowed to literally run a
show
of racist muppets but tucker carlson
should be pulled off the air
that's basically what they're saying
when democrats write to these cable
companies to remove
conservative news channels also i mean
the ramifications of this this is the
government
agents of the government trying to force
private companies into shutting down
their political rivals
to be fair tucker carlson kind of looks
like one of the muppets i forgot which
one
uh but there's like a news reporter one
but that's he does
it's a compliment also another thing
they're going after fox news for
spreading
misinformation and quote conspiracy
theories i mean these are from
democratic congress members calling for
ceos of tv companies and internet
providers to take down
another news channel that doesn't
subscribe to the same notions i don't
like fox i i made a
shirt against fox even myself even cnn
with the toilet and everything
i don't like any of these kind of
partisan networks but the bigger kind of
understanding here is
if these people are going to take them
down from misinformation and conspiracy
theories
they have to take themselves down at the
same time i thought of a funny joke
did you so we were just talking about
the previous segment like what are white
people good at
and then you mentioned some people said
oppression yeah but
you see they only steal that from china
right so i was i'm looking we're looking
at the story and i'm like i'm thinking
about
these like these these democrats trying
to get news banned and i'm like man
maybe they really are good at oppressive
wait a minute
what they're doing is a rip off of what
china already did
and then i thought it's another funny
joke because then the other stereotype
about white people that you get from the
progressives is that they steal culture
so maybe right now the democrats are
really good at stealing the
authoritarianism from these
despotic nations hey and now there you
go it's an idea
that is an idea i mean look i think
china was very good
at banning basically all media that
didn't agree with the government so
they're like right ahead of us yeah they
are yeah i'm sorry just
these these white progressives are just
not good at oppression no they're trying
though
is this cultural appropriation then
appropriating yeah so
yeah i mean culturally oh oh they should
stop they should they just
i'm sorry it is racist for them to try
and shut down
opinions of those they don't like
exactly because they're just ripping off
china there you go
take note liberals what is this what
does this look ian
stroking your beard i'm taking it all
away
it's a lot look this is uh uh i wonder
to what degree this is a violation of
the first amendment
for for trying to shut down all the news
yeah well what these what these
democrats are doing they're acting
they act they're they're agents of
government
and they're going and trying to get
political views taken off
they're not going to these channels
they're literally going to
the providers and saying you know why
are you still hosting them this
misinformation these lies
i mean this is the kind of stuff that
makes me pessimistic it makes me feel
like we're headed towards
absurdity it's like you've got criticism
they don't they're doing too much
these these politicians it's if you're
driving down the road on a freeway you
don't need to be turning left and right
and it's like we got people in jobs that
don't need to be there anymore or
something
they don't need to change it you know
what you're like you've talked about us
before ian
that like maybe we don't need these
politicians anymore you mentioned
like less politicians and like different
branches and stuff like that i'm
wondering if
you know oh why do they make new laws
you know what i mean
they're constantly making new laws why
don't they get rid of old ones well
that's the thing is like
so with this whole lockdown stuff and
this is totally on the side but it
goes to what you said i always think
like governments are really good at
stomping on your freedoms how often do
they give them back
so it's like when when they legislate
it's like you said like for every and i
think that was trump's thing
you know for every how many laws were
passed you know however many were
repealed and i think that or you know
all this red tape was cut and i think
that you're right like they're always
passing new laws but it's like for
what what are you doing actually day to
day
that is necessary that needs to be done
it's more regulation
most of the time taking your guns away
yes
they're getting there they're trying so
yeah they did it in australia oh they
did and then after they took away the
firearms in australia the australian
government locked down and clamped down
on its citizenry
uh more than almost any government out
there especially when it came to the
covid restrictions and it was kind of
it still is absurd to see what they're
able to get away with over there oh it's
terrible
like i don't know so aussies and i think
have just a fundamental disagreement
some of these and i have a fundamental
disagreement when it comes to this this
is part of why i left
because my frustration was like i'm
watching america which mind you i know
that a lot of americans think that
america is just rightly screwed right
now
to some extent maybe but you still have
a constitution and a bill of rights and
a bunch of stuff that protects you
australians not so much we don't have
freedom of speech that's an implied
thing in our constitution
we don't have a bill of rights we have
five rights in our constitution and
there are things like freedom of
religion and you know you can move
between states and things like that
so watching what was going down with all
the lockdown stuff having no guns yada
yada
it was honestly really you know i'm here
in the us and i'm thinking
i'm so lucky to live in a country where
i can actually just basically be like
you know what
nah and do what i want i think that
that's great even living in texas you
can just buy a
million guns in australia there was
people who organized
protests on facebook and literally had
police officers break down their front
door with when they were having dinners
with their family with
children there and arrested and took
them away
from their children for organizing a
protest oh yeah yeah that was one there
was a pregnant girl
this one i believe you're talking about
yeah there's a number of them yeah yeah
um
it's funny because one of my very good
friends back home his name is avi and
he's a journalist for
rebel news um he was he's been arrested
several times now
even though he has press credentials
from the government to be you know
at these protests and things and he has
been arrested he's been chucked in the
back of the divi van where the the
police
van thingy um and they they really
target
the journalists now they arrested one i
think it was two or three days ago they
arrest another young journalist and her
photographer from the herald sun which
is another
melbourne newspaper and the thing that
really distresses me watching this
like again from a country where i can
basically do a lot of things that i
can't do back home
is they just snap their fingers and go
okay we're having another lock down now
five day lockdown everyone like stay in
your home can't go outside can't do this
can't do that and australians just go
okay yes daddy government yes yes yes
i'll do the thing
okay yup and i it makes me want to throw
up because i think
where is your sense of freedom where's
your sense of self-preservation it's not
i mean they think that the government
will answer all of their hopes and
dreams and questions when in reality
the government is actually just stomping
on you the first the first 15 days
we all basically agreed exactly every
week days two weeks
yeah and we were all like yeah that
makes sense but then when they extended
it we still agreed we were like all
right
let's let's let's slow this thing down
we're all in this together right
and then after i think the first year
like we're at now everyone's kind of
like dude come on man yeah
look at look you look at we're looking
at global food shortages
we're looking at massive poverty and it
it
it feels like they're just destroying
everything on purpose
because they don't care they don't care
that lives are being ruined they don't
how many politicians took a pay like
had a decrease in pay during this time
how many politicians didn't get paid
i think they all got paid you know the
premier of
in victoria so where i'm from the
premier of my home state gave himself a
pay raise
during the pandemic after he locked down
victorians for the longest period i'm
pretty sure in the entire world
and then this i want to call him the c
word but i'm not going to say it but
then he goes
he goes and gives him and i nearly
slipped out i was like sydney
he goes and gives himself a pay raise
how many of these people and even in the
us
how many of them have taken a pay cut
well how many of them have not yet
gotten paid andrew cuomo got a raise
he's working very hard oh yeah for these
people he deserves more
daily press conferences lying to you
giving you his little smile he's a
sociopath they're not lies
they're comforting distortions he's
trying to just
avert panic and make everyone feel good
oh and it does they feel really
you know what the thing is if you value
security more than freedom i don't know
what to tell you
and it's not misinformation it's
comfortable news
comfortable comfort this guy is that you
guys should go look him up you'll have a
field day especially tim
yeah we uh i i'm glad i don't live in
australia because
where is it like victoria is that the
the are they is it called a state or is
it a province or what is it
state yeah we have states states and
territories yeah and that's where they
basically
put everybody in like home jail home
home arrest or whatever yeah basically
yeah i mean like again aussies look i
love australians but sometimes you know
they get on me and they're like you're
so mean where are some unibodies truly
and i'm like
i don't know because you got no freedom
like i don't know
wait you're you're half american though
right yeah so that's that's the thing
you're a day walker you you understand
that it seems like you've got the best
uh you inherited the best of both sides
like the ability to fight giant
tarantulas and like kangaroos
while understanding the importance of
freedom yeah exactly that's the craziest
thing to me is that
you could have australia which is the
stereotypical stereotypical
stereotypical death trap country
of like giant spiders and birds i watch
this video where there's a super
jacked kangaroo banging on some guy's
window you saw that one yeah yeah yeah
and he's like what's
and and this australian guy i knew said
like they could gut you they could like
their huge claws
slash you i'm like how do you grow up in
a place where i watch one video where
these people are drinking on an outdoor
patio and a kangaroo just like stomps
through yeah
and but you know what maybe that's
actually what it is they're scared of
everything
and so when the government comes in
they're like please help us from the
giant mean monsters
you know and so they hide they hide you
know look
i grew up in the country so we always
around ruse and stuff they are very
aggressive people need to understand
don't chase them do not corner them
you're gonna get your little face ripped
off they are they've got these little
creases right you see them like flex
oh yeah they are they're dragged i think
it's bigger than this tim i think it's
the queen
she has to be responsible for her you're
right luke yeah i keep thinking about it
canada the united kingdom australia
toughest strictest lockdowns all of them
colonies with the queen yeah it's all
the commonwealth stuff isn't it yep
no i mean that's actually i wonder
because i know that i don't actually
don't
that was not a nonsensical sentence you
also have to look at new zealand too
because they have been like i love it i
love it when people are like new
zealand's dealing with this so well
new zealand's an island in the middle of
the pacific with nothing around it
except other oceans and a very small
population is a tiny population isn't it
two thousand miles from australia
i don't know in terms of proximity it's
it's like a three-hour plane ride to get
to new zealand
that sounds like about two thousand well
if you look in the united kingdom i mean
even their lockdowns are absolutely
absurd and
very oddly yeah it doesn't make many
sense
on many different levels because if you
look at the numbers you compare it
to sweden um the numbers are going down
the same way they're even going down
even more according to some estimates in
sweden
where the lockdowns were restricted by
and large
not fully but by and large compared to
the united kingdom that fully lock down
and of course has their police officer
sending out notices that they will no
longer be responding to
burglaries but they spent taxpayer money
on billboard buses telling you that
being offensive
is a criminal offense oh you know the uk
is just
ah it's beautiful it's again it's one of
these beautiful prisons
yeah that's australia is a beautiful
prison aussies don't yell at me for
saying that i love you
this is a bit of a prison bloody you
know gulag i think is a better the uk
yeah they're beautiful but they're
prisons because like you know
these are countries that arrest people
not australia so much they do it a
little bit but not that much but they
arrest people for things they post
online and it's like
it's ridiculous oh my god 2 583.3 miles
new zealand to australia i just think
that's relevant because people think
australia and new zealand are very close
to each other no they're it's a
yeah it's super fast yeah definitely and
i think new zealand has like 4 million
people
5 million i think 5 million yeah when i
went to new zealand they asked me why i
was there and i was going there to
interview this guy gareth morgan
and they all knew who he was so when i
was at like the the immigration
checkpoint they were like what you're
here for i'm like i'm here with you know
vice magazine we're gonna interview this
guy
and they're like who is it and i was
like his name's gareth morgan oh i know
him
and i was like you're doing the like
there's not that many people in this
country man
it's like everybody knows if someone
here is famous everybody knows who it is
i was expecting you to do a an accent it
sounded like you were going there i was
i was i was gearing up i was like oh tim
i almost did i almost went for it you
know well you know a tough one it's it's
you know i used to do a really good new
zealand accent but i've got to hear it
first
and it's been too long so like i
wouldn't get i'm unable to just
get my toes in a little bit you have you
have a like a day walker accent
my accent is just an absolute mess and
honestly it depends who i'm around too
because if i'm
if i'm around a bunch of yanks i feel
like my accent gets much more american
when i'm around other yeah you guys are
yanks all of you like no matter where
you're from you're all yanks
but when i talk to like you know if i
call home and i'm talking to like my dad
who is
very australian he's from perth so his
accent is just like off the planet
um but if i like call home or something
people are like oh you're just
you're using your own terminology again
i'm like yeah my accent sucks
it's don't ask i don't know did you live
in the u.s for a long forever
before no no i'm just you know it's
funny when people are like so
um are you putting this on i'm like yeah
i'm trying to do both accents badly
your mom was american my mom's america
okay but moved over there
yep fell in love fell in love with my
dad citizenship
yep um so i mean i got questions about
the british monarchy
growing up were you like the queen were
you
were you aware that you lived under the
rule of a queen
she said she was the head of state yeah
she's our head but it's very like
subversive
you don't know you're kind of led to
believe that you live in a free state
yeah yeah yeah i
so when i became aware of the fact that
because obviously like when you're at
school you learn about aussie history
you don't learn about british history
you learn about aussie history you learn
about federation
you know like when um the first fleet
landed in australia and colonized yada
yada we learn about all of that
um i didn't know probably until i was
actually
maybe in my late teens that we weren't a
republic
because i remember we studied stuff at
school and i was like oh well you know i
would probably vote to have us be a
republican
i had friends who were like nope i want
to be you know we need them on our case
deal and that's a whole that's actually
a whole argument
is a lot of conservatives in australia
are like we need to still
be part of you know or at least have the
monarchy as like our head of state so to
speak even though it's
the queen we she gives royal ascent on
all of our legislation that gets passed
so i mean it's it's more of a ceremonial
thing but it's still active i guess
like she controls the military and so
she is she the one ordering these
lockdowns
no but she's not saying no to them she's
she's she's
dissenting to them what if there's like
a secret conspiracy where the queen
actually is giving instructions to her
subjects and she's actually controlling
new zealand and australia
well i think it's funny to call it a
conspiracy when she's literally the
queen the monster the head of state
foreign
leader of the country by divine
providence
she's queen of the britons thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time